This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Helen Zoltzmann's The Illusionist is a show about language and words. That's kind of like saying that this show is about architecture and design. The description doesn't quite capture the way we use those lenses to view the world at large. My favorite words are eponyms. If you don't know what an epinem is, you are about to find out. Because I love epinems so much, each year Helen produces an episode of the illusionist about epinems, which feature me talking a little bit. And we put two of those episodes together for you to enjoy. One quick note, Helen is from the UK, where
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。海伦·扎尔茨曼的《幻觉师》是一档关于语言和词汇的节目。这就像说我的节目是关于建筑和设计的。这种描述并不能完全涵盖我们如何利用这些视角来观察广阔的世界。我最喜欢的词是“同源词”（eponyms）。如果你不知道什么是同源词，你马上就会知道了。因为我太喜欢同源词了，海伦每年都会制作一期关于同源词的《幻觉师》节目，其中会有我的一些谈话。我们把其中两期节目放在一起供大家欣赏。顺便提一下，海伦来自英国，在那里
they often refer to ballpoint pens as byros. You would have picked that up through contacts, but I just wanted to eliminate that half-second of confusion that you might have if you're not from there. All right, without further ado, here's Helen's ultimates, the illusionist. A while ago, Roman tweeted the following, I would totally listen to an ongoing radio series comprised solely of the stories behind eponyms. Firstly, I thought, what's an eponym? Eponym, now, a word or name derived from the name of a person, or a person after whom a discovery, invention, place, etc. is named. Secondly, I wondered what it was about eponyms that got Roman so excited. An eponym, just almost by definition, has some kind of story, even if it isn't the origin
他们经常把圆珠笔称为“byros”。如果你不是那里的人，你可能通过接触了解过这一点，但我只是想消除你可能产生的半秒钟困惑。好了，废话少说，这是海伦的终极节目——《幻觉师》。不久前，罗曼发了这样一条推文：“我绝对会听一个持续的广播系列，专门讲述同源词背后的故事。”首先，我想，什么是同源词？同源词，现在指源自人名的词或名称，或者以某人的名字命名某项发现、发明、地点等。其次，我很好奇为什么罗曼对同源词如此兴奋。一个同源词，几乎从定义上讲，都有某种故事，即使它不是起源
story, it has something where it got the eponym attached to it, which is a good enough story to be retold. And so for that reason, I just kind of love them and it sort of starts a good conversation, I think. That's what I love about eponyms. I've always liked silhouette because I think it's a little bit of a slur if I have this right. The idea, like, really elaborate painting portraiture was in fashion. Silhouette was the head of the French treasury, was cutting back into their version of austerity.
故事，它也有某种被赋予这个同源词的原因，这足以成为一个值得重述的故事。正因如此，我非常喜欢它们，而且我认为这能开启一段很好的对话。这就是我喜欢同源词的原因。我一直很喜欢“剪影”（silhouette），因为如果我没记错的话，它带有一点贬义。当时，那种非常精致的绘画肖像很流行。而Silhouette是法国财政部长，他当时正在推行紧缩政策。
That's right at the time when outline drawings were becoming in fashion, which are clearly not as elaborate, didn't require an artist, and require months of time. And so that type of a portrait was a la silhouette, like a really like stripped down, simple, didn't require or a skill.
这正好是在轮廓画开始流行的时候，这些画显然没那么精致，不需要艺术家，也不需要几个月的时间。所以那种肖像画被称为“a la silhouette”，就像是一种非常精简、简单、不需要技巧的东西。
And I love that, because it's a bit of a slight at the same time as being descriptive. And so I love those ones like that. Well, if you like silhouette Roman, you're probably going to love Baudlerisation after the English editor Thomas Baudler, who in 1818 released a version of Shakespeare's plays that he'd reworked to make them more suitable for women and children, as in, he'd taken out all of the naughty bits and foul language. So, Lady Macbeth doesn't even say her famous line, out, out, damn spot anymore, but out, crimson spot, as if she's in a laundry
我喜欢这一点，因为它既具有描述性，又带有一点轻蔑。所以我喜欢这类词。好吧，如果你喜欢“剪影”，罗曼，你可能会喜欢“鲍德勒化”（Baudlerisation），它源自英国编辑托马斯·鲍德勒，他在1818年发布了一个莎士比亚戏剧版本，他对其进行了重写，使其更适合妇女和儿童，也就是说，他删除了所有不雅的内容和粗俗的语言。所以，麦克白夫人甚至不再说她那句名言“去吧，去吧，该死的污点”，而是说“去吧，深红色的污点”，就好像她在洗衣
detergent advert. To be fair, Badel is addition was actually a huge success and brought Shakespeare to a much wider audience, but his name does now stand for CAC-handed explication. When it comes to word origins, an F&M is the surest bet that you're going to get a good story out of it. That's what I love about them. And it's taken me this long to realize. I know. What is your problem?
剂广告里一样。平心而论，鲍德勒的版本实际上取得了巨大的成功，并将莎士比亚带给了更广泛的受众，但他的名字现在却代表了笨拙的删改。谈到词源，同源词是你能得到好故事的最可靠保证。这就是我喜欢它们的原因。我花了这么长时间才意识到这一点。我知道。你有什么问题？
I told you from the very beginning, it should just be an F&M show. Yeah. I love them. So you should start. Do one. Do a regular one every six weeks. Just do an F&M. Oh, I'll see. I'll see how I love them. So you should start, do one, do a regular one every six weeks, do an ebb and an. I'll see. I'll see how this one goes. Yeah. I'm going to start small with some
我从一开始就告诉你，这应该就是一个同源词节目。是的。我喜欢它们。所以你应该开始。做一个吧。每六周做一个常规节目。就做一个同源词节目。哦，我会考虑的。我会看看……我喜欢它们。所以你应该开始，做一个，每六周做一个常规节目，做一个同源词节目。我会考虑的。我会看看这一期效果如何。是的。我要从小处着手，从一些
eponymous items you're probably all familiar with. You might be holding one right now, the BIC and the BIRO. I chose these for the first epinim's attempt because I thought they're in the spirit of both Roman show 99% invisible, which examines a lot of commonplace objects, and of this one, because this is a show about words, and what is stationary without words, and words without stationary. Stationery is the physical infrastructure of words. That is James Ward, author of Adventures in Stationery, a journey through your pencil case. So James knows a lot about ballpoint pens, which we might casually refer to as
你可能都很熟悉的同源词物品开始。你现在手里可能就拿着一个，BIC和BIRO。我选择这些作为第一次同源词尝试，是因为我认为它们既符合罗曼的《99%隐形》的精神，该节目审视了许多常见的物品，也符合本节目的精神，因为这是一档关于词汇的节目，没有词汇的文具是什么，没有文具的词汇又是什么？文具是词汇的物理基础设施。那是詹姆斯·沃德，著有《文具冒险：文具盒之旅》。所以詹姆斯对圆珠笔了解很多，我们可能会随意地称之为
byros or bicks. I guess what's kind of interesting is that for lots of people they're just one thing. So people say a big byroe. And is that controversial? It's kind of odd in the same way as you, I mean, you wouldn't say I'm going to have a can of Pepsi Coke or I suppose you might say I just bought a new Dyson Hoover, which is, I guess it's when one brand or name becomes the generic and the other one remains the specific. How do you think Biro managed to become the generic?
“byros”或“bicks”。我想有趣的是，对很多人来说，它们就是同一种东西。所以人们会说“一个BIC byro”。这有争议吗？这有点奇怪，就像你，我的意思是，你不会说“我要喝一罐百事可乐”，或者我想你可能会说“我刚买了一个新的戴森吸尘器”，我想这就是当一个品牌或名称成为通用名称，而另一个仍然是特定名称的时候。你认为Biro是如何成为通用名称的？
Lazzlo Biro, he, I mean, he didn't invent the ballpoint, but he kind of perfected it. The invention of the ballpoint going by a patent filed in 1888 is credited to John J. Loud, who had a great name for a product, but not a good pen, which left room for Lazlo Biro to swoop in and claim ballpoint victory. Born in Budapest in 1899, Lazlo Barrow had been variously, a medical student, a stage hypnotist and insurance salesman, a race car driver, and eventually he became a journalist, which was what he was working as in the early 1930s, when he invented the pen that would make his name, and indeed take his name. And apparently when they were here in the print room and the heat of the machinery caused his fountain pen
拉斯洛·比罗（Lazzlo Biro），我的意思是，他并没有发明圆珠笔，但他将其完善了。圆珠笔的发明，根据1888年提交的一项专利，归功于约翰·J·劳德（John J. Loud），他为产品起了一个好名字，但笔本身并不好用，这为拉斯洛·比罗介入并夺取圆珠笔的胜利留下了空间。拉斯洛·比罗1899年出生于布达佩斯，曾做过医学生、舞台催眠师、保险推销员、赛车手，最终成为一名记者，这就是他在20世纪30年代初发明那支让他成名，并确实以他名字命名的笔时所从事的工作。显然，当他们在印刷室时，机器产生的热量导致他的钢笔
to leak. And so he wanted to develop an alternative way of creating a pen that didn't leak due to the heat and pressure. And he saw the way that the cylindrical print presses rolled the ink onto the page. And so he thought, oh, if only you could have like a miniature version of those,
漏墨了。所以他想开发一种替代方法来制造一支不会因为热量和压力而漏墨的笔。他看到了圆柱形印刷机将油墨滚到页面上的方式。于是他想，哦，如果能有一个微缩版本就好了，
but the problem is that a cylinder can only roll in forwards and backwards, whereas when you're writing it needs to roll in all directions. And the story there is almost certainly not true, but is frequently told is he was sitting in a cafe looking out of the window trying to make sense of how you'd make a cylinder roll in all directions. And it had been raining outside and there's some kids playing with marbles and one of them rolled marbles through a puddle and then he saw the line of water that the marble made on the pavement and then he suddenly realized, oh well, a ball rolls in all directions. That seems quite obvious that a ball rolls in all directions. I mean, that seems quite obvious that a ball rolls in all directions.
但问题是圆柱体只能前后滚动，而当你书写时，它需要向各个方向滚动。这个故事几乎肯定不是真的，但经常被讲述：他当时坐在咖啡馆里看着窗外，试图弄清楚如何让圆柱体向各个方向滚动。外面下着雨，有一些孩子在玩弹珠，其中一个孩子把弹珠滚过水坑，然后他看到了弹珠在人行道上留下的水线，他突然意识到，哦，原来球可以向各个方向滚动。这似乎很明显，球可以向各个方向滚动。我的意思是，这似乎很明显，球可以向各个方向滚动。
Like all ball games are based on that principle, but it took him, these children playing with marbles for him to make the connection. And he had like this weird experience. I think he was like checking into a hotel and he signed in using his prototype pen and the guy next to him kind of saw the pen and was like, oh, that's rather interesting. Tell me about your pen. It's not the best pickup line, but that passing pen enthusiast turns out to be the former president of Argentina visiting Europe
就像所有的球类运动都是基于这个原理，但他花了很长时间，直到看到这些孩子玩弹珠才建立起联系。他有一次奇怪的经历。我想他当时正在办理酒店入住手续，用他的原型笔签了名，旁边的人看到了这支笔，说：“哦，这很有趣。跟我说说你的笔吧。”这不是最好的搭讪方式，但那个路过的笔爱好者竟然是正在访问欧洲的阿根廷前总统，
to promote trade links. So in due course, Lazló Bairó moved to Argentina to grow his pen empire. Penpire? These kind of stories that they had these prototype pens and they take them to meetings to try and get investors. And Lazló would be doing all of the talking and his colleague would be under the table, he'd be like, because some of the pens worked and some of the pens didn't. And so he'd get out a little scrap of paper and he'd be sort of scribbling on a bit of paper to try and get the pen to work. And if it started working, then he'd go, oh, and here's a sample. Whereas if it didn't start working, then he'd give him a signal. And as I'd be like,
旨在促进贸易联系。于是，拉斯洛·比罗搬到了阿根廷，发展他的笔帝国。笔帝国？他们有这些原型笔，带去开会试图寻找投资者。拉斯洛会负责所有的谈话，而他的同事会在桌子底下，他会像这样，因为有些笔能用，有些不能。所以他会拿出一张小纸片，在上面乱涂乱画，试图让笔出墨。如果开始出墨了，他就会说：“哦，这是一个样品。”而如果没出墨，他就会给他一个信号。我会像这样，
unfortunately, we don't have any prototypes with us, but welcome, next time we come. So, ByRose were a bit rubbish. They had lots of problems that they had to resolve. They had to find an ink that was viscous enough that it wouldn't leak out, but then not so thick that it would clog or jam. They had to find a way that you could keep it in like a jacket pocket and it wouldn't overheat
“很遗憾，我们没有带原型笔，但欢迎下次再来。”所以，Biro笔有点垃圾。他们必须解决很多问题。他们必须找到一种粘度足够高、不会漏出来的油墨，但又不能太稠，以免堵塞或卡住。他们必须找到一种方法，让你把它放在夹克口袋里也不会过热
and make the pen leak. So once they cracked it, then other people were able to come along and go, oh, this is great. So Pyro teams up with Henry Martin, who was involved in like the aeronautics industry in the UK, because he needed, in order to make the pen, he needed ball bearings, or very, very fine ball bearings and aviation industry makes the best ball bearings. And then, I mean, this is during the Second World War at this point, but they started manufacturing these ball point pens and they gave them to the RAF
导致笔漏墨。所以一旦他们解决了这个问题，其他人就能跟进说：“哦，这太棒了。”于是比罗与亨利·马丁合作，他参与了英国的航空工业，因为为了制造这支笔，他需要滚珠轴承，或者非常非常精细的滚珠轴承，而航空工业制造最好的滚珠轴承。然后，我的意思是，这已经是第二次世界大战期间了，但他们开始制造这些圆珠笔，并把它们提供给英国皇家空军，
because if you're flying really high and you need to write down a coordinates or whatever, you won't depend that's not going to leak because of the air pressure. And these pens worked. Who Ray, but it wasn't all smooth rolling thence fourth. There was a lot of competition, albeit mostly rubbish. In the United States, a man called Milton Reynolds wanted to be the first to launch a ballpoint in that country. Yeah, the Reynolds International, and it was described as this kind of atomic age, super pen. He didn't actually put in much effort to make the super pen a super pen.
因为如果你飞得很高，需要写下坐标什么的，你需要一支不会因为气压而漏墨的笔。这些笔成功了。万岁，但此后的滚动并不总是那么顺利。竞争非常激烈，尽管大多是垃圾。在美国，一个叫米尔顿·雷诺兹的人想成为该国第一个推出圆珠笔的人。是的，雷诺兹国际公司，它被描述为一种原子时代的超级笔。他实际上并没有花太多精力让这支超级笔成为真正的超级笔。
He just wanted to be the first to market, so everyone bought his pen. He was a kind of opportunistic, uh, Huxster. He kind of just rushed out this, this pen, which caused like a sensation at the time. It went at first launched first launched in New York, there were just crowds like thousands of people lining the streets. Is it like a Pennsylvania for pens? Yeah, or you know, when there's like a new iPhone or something,
他只是想成为第一个上市的人，所以每个人都买了这支笔。他是一个机会主义的……小贩。他只是匆忙推出了这支笔，在当时引起了轰动。它在纽约首次推出时，街上挤满了成千上万的人。这就像是笔界的宾夕法尼亚州吗？是的，或者你知道，当有新款iPhone发布时，
it was like that, but for pens, it was crappy. And it came with a guarantee that if it broke within two years, then they'd replace it and they'd just have to replace hundreds of thousands of these things. In the US, that created the market for the ballpoint, but it also then nearly killed it off because people had this terrible experience of these bad, bad pens. But then another major ballpoint player entered the fray, a manufacturer of fountain pens who kept getting enquiries for ballpoint pen parts, Marcel Bick, spelt B-I-C-H. But for his eponymous pen, he dropped the H so that you wouldn't think
就像那样，但那是针对笔的，而且它很烂。它附带一个保证，如果两年内坏了就更换，结果他们不得不更换成千上万支。在美国，这创造了圆珠笔市场，但也差点毁了它，因为人们对这些糟糕的笔有非常糟糕的体验。但随后另一位主要的圆珠笔参与者进入了竞争，一位钢笔制造商，他不断收到对圆珠笔零件的询问，马塞尔·比克（Marcel Bich），拼写为B-I-C-H。但为了他的同名笔，他去掉了H，这样你就不会认为
the Bick crystal was pronounced Bick or Bitch or any other way than Bick. This was after the war that the Bick came along and they licensed the technology from Biro. There were these very complicated legal battles where each party kept suing the other one because they claimed an infringement and Miles Martin, which was the UK company that Byro was involved with. They were suing BIC and there was all of these complications
Bic水晶笔的发音是“Bick”或“Bitch”，或者除了“Bick”以外的任何发音。这是在战后Bic出现之后，他们从比罗那里获得了技术许可。当时发生了非常复杂的法律斗争，双方不断起诉对方，因为他们声称侵权，而Miles Martin，也就是比罗参与的英国公司，他们正在起诉BIC，所有这些复杂的情况
and then sort of with Richard Curtis for a romantic comedy inevitability. Henry Martin, who ran Miles Martin at company and his son married the daughter of Marcel Bick. So it's real Romeo and Juliet stuff. Yeah, but you can imagine that it must have been tricky when they're choosing which pen to sign the marriage certificate with. Maybe they just went for a pencil. Yeah, Bick grew and grew and grew. And how did they manage that? Because that particular pen, the big crystal, the one that everyone refers to, has the big
然后就像理查德·柯蒂斯的浪漫喜剧一样不可避免。经营Miles Martin公司的亨利·马丁的儿子娶了马塞尔·比克的女儿。所以这真是罗密欧与朱丽叶的故事。是的，但你可以想象，当他们选择用哪支笔签署结婚证书时，一定很棘手。也许他们只是用了一支铅笔。是的，Bic不断壮大。他们是怎么做到的？因为那支特定的笔，Bic水晶笔，每个人都提到的那支，拥有Bic
biro with its hexagonal body and it's familiar cap with the hole in the end. And that particular pen just works. So it's meritocracy. So yeah, exactly. And it's something like, I think half of all ballpoint pens that's holding the world every day are bit crystals. So if you think how many other millions of types of ballpoints that there are, like there's supermarket or own brand versions.
Biro笔的六角形笔身和末端有孔的熟悉笔盖。而那支特定的笔就是好用。所以这是精英管理。所以是的，完全正确。而且我认为，每天支撑世界的圆珠笔中，有一半是Bic水晶笔。所以如果你想想还有多少其他数百万种圆珠笔，比如超市自有品牌版本。
I've got this one I stole from a hotel. Yeah, there's the same to show it to you. The hotel, the bit crystal just works and it's, there's the... It's a shame to show it to you. It's stolen hotel, the big crystal just works and it's... There's one in the permanent collection of the Museum of Modern Art in New York. I don't know if it's necessarily always on display, but they've got it in their collection somewhere. You have to ask. Yeah, you have to book a head.
我这支是从酒店偷来的。是的，给你展示一下。酒店，Bic水晶笔就是好用，而且……给你展示一下真是可惜。这是偷来的酒店笔，Bic水晶笔就是好用，而且……纽约现代艺术博物馆的永久收藏中就有一支。我不知道它是否总是展出，但他们确实在收藏中。你得问问。是的，你得提前预约。
You have to pay $20 to see a pen that you could buy for $0.50. Yeah, but it's a different experience. Let's take a little etymology break. Pen and pencil may share a syllable, but don't let that GPU into thinking they have a common linguistic origin. Pen derives from the Latin penna, which meant feather. So saying quill pen is a topology good to know.
你得花20美元去看一支你花0.5美元就能买到的笔。是的，但这是一种不同的体验。让我们休息一下，谈谈词源。Pen（钢笔）和Pencil（铅笔）可能共享一个音节，但不要让这让你认为它们有共同的语言起源。Pen源自拉丁语“penna”，意思是羽毛。所以说“羽毛笔”（quill pen）是同义反复，很高兴知道这一点。
Pencil, meanwhile, came from the Latin for a painter's brush. Penna's sillis, a diminutive of peniculus, which meant little tail, and the Latin for tail is also where we get the word penis. Anyway, back to pens and how their development influenced the development of writing itself. The ability to make marks more precisely means that you're able to make more complex marks. So if all you have is a bit of stick and a clay tablet, you can only produce quite basic scripts, so like you know, form is quite angular. And but then if you start using like a read brush
与此同时，Pencil来自拉丁语的画家画笔。Penna's sillis，是peniculus的小称，意思是小尾巴，而拉丁语中的尾巴也是我们得到“penis”（阴茎）这个词的地方。总之，回到笔以及它们的发展如何影响了书写本身的发展。能够更精确地做标记意味着你能够做出更复杂的标记。所以如果你只有一根棍子和一块泥板，你只能产生相当基础的文字，比如楔形文字是相当有棱角的。但如果你开始使用芦苇笔
on a pirus, that offers you more flexibility. And then if you start using instead of a pirus which is quite rough if you use parchment on a vellum which is extremely smooth and you use a quill which is very flexible then you're able to produce extremely beautiful like illustrated texts or illuminated texts and so with those developments it means that the characters that you're able to produce are it more easy to distinguish. So you're able to have more characters
在莎草纸上，那会给你更多的灵活性。然后如果你开始使用，而不是相当粗糙的莎草纸，如果你使用羊皮纸或牛皮纸，它们非常光滑，而且你使用非常灵活的羽毛笔，那么你就能够制作出极其精美的插图文本或装饰文本，所以随着这些发展，这意味着你能够产生的字符更容易区分。所以你能够拥有更多的字符
until you're able to produce writing, which is more complex, I suppose. My school would only let us use fountain pens. We were not allowed to write with ball points. And this seems to have been quite a common attitude towards ball points for a long time. A fountain pen can produce thick lines, thin lines, flourishes, and thus invest your handwriting with a lot of character and flair.
直到你能够产生书写，我想这更复杂。我的学校只允许我们使用钢笔。我们不允许用圆珠笔写字。长期以来，这似乎是对圆珠笔的一种相当普遍的态度。钢笔可以产生粗线条、细线条、花体，从而为你的笔迹注入很多个性和风格。
But the ball in a ball point produces a line of uniform thickness. So a lot of people believe that the pens were detrimental to handwriting. Laslos' daughter, she said, her father would often respond to these complaints. And he used to hear people say that the ballpoint was ruining writing skills, and he'd smile and say, well, writing comes from the heart if we can help the hand to perform the task, what it's so wrong with that. And I think there's nothing wrong with that. Well done, let's say, Byro. I think it's interesting, but their names are on products that are extremely successful,
但圆珠笔里的球产生的是粗细均匀的线条。所以很多人认为这些笔对笔迹有害。拉斯洛的女儿说，她父亲经常回应这些抱怨。他过去常听到人们说圆珠笔正在毁掉书写技能，他会微笑着说：“好吧，书写源于内心，如果我们能帮助手完成任务，那有什么错呢？”我认为这没什么错。做得好，比罗。我认为这很有趣，但他们的名字出现在极其成功的产品上，
but also disposable. their names are on products that are extremely successful, but also disposable. Yeah, and also they are kind of disposable in that you can know what a big is or you can know what a biro is, but you don't need to know who Marcel is or who Lazlo is. So they've kind of made this disposable contribution to history
但也同时是消耗品。他们的名字出现在极其成功的产品上，但也同时是消耗品。是的，而且它们在某种程度上也是消耗品，因为你可以知道什么是Bic，或者你可以知道什么是Biro，但你不需要知道马塞尔是谁，或者拉斯洛是谁。所以他们以某种方式对历史做出了消耗性的贡献，
and in the same way they've made themselves disposable. So, if your eponymous product is successful, your involvement in it and even your own identity is subsumed, which might not sit that well with the kind of people who put their names on things, because calling something after yourself seems like quite an ego-miniical choice to me. I mean, I may be wrong,
同样地，他们也让自己变得可有可无。所以，如果你的同名产品成功了，你对它的参与甚至你自己的身份都会被淹没，这可能不太适合那些把名字印在东西上的人，因为以自己的名字命名某物对我来说似乎是一个相当自负的选择。我的意思是，我可能错了，
but my impression is a lot of epinems are not the person naming them after themselves. It's more of an assigned by another person. It's like a mark of respect. Yeah. Do you think that people who've got a disease or horrible medical condition named after them? That's quite a sad way to be remembered, isn't it? I don't know. It depends because if you're a researcher, you've probably gotten past the feeling of grossness around disease and you probably just enjoy the fact that you were instrumental in its discovery or successful treatment. So I have a feeling that I could even live with a horrible disease being named after me. Yeah, but then you'd have people who only remember you because you're what killed their grandma.
但我的印象是，很多同源词并不是本人以自己的名字命名的。这更多是别人赋予的。这是一种尊重的标志。是的。你认为那些患有疾病或可怕的医疗状况并以他们名字命名的人怎么想？那是一种相当悲伤的被记住的方式，不是吗？我不知道。这取决于，因为如果你是一名研究人员，你可能已经克服了对疾病的恶心感，你可能只是享受这样一个事实：你在它的发现或成功治疗中发挥了作用。所以我有一种感觉，即使是一种可怕的疾病以我的名字命名，我也能接受。是的，但那样的话，人们记住你只是因为你是杀死他们祖母的原因。
And you feel good about that. Yeah. Just be remembered. I think that's the most important thing it doesn't matter what it's for. That's what serial killers are banking on. Yeah. And now part two of the illusionist Epinim's saga, where we learn some bad news about Epinim's.
你对此感觉良好吗？是的。只要被记住就行。我认为这是最重要的，不管是为了什么。这就是连环杀手所依赖的。是的。现在是《幻觉师》同源词传奇的第二部分，我们将了解到关于同源词的一些坏消息。
There's a shift, a gradual shift away from using Epinim's in medicine. Who's this enemy of Epinim's? My name's Isaac Siemens, and I'm a resident physician in the department of family and community medicine at the University of Toronto. There's two camps in medicine currently, people who want to use eponyms and people who want to move away from eponyms and there's there's a few different reasons for that. People that are more in touch with history perhaps and then people that are more moving towards kind of accuracy in language, in broad strokes, that's the controversy. You can see the practical case for this shift.
医学界正在发生转变，逐渐远离使用同源词。这个同源词的敌人是谁？我叫艾萨克·西门子，我是多伦多大学家庭与社区医学系的住院医师。目前医学界有两个阵营，想要使用同源词的人和想要远离同源词的人，这有几个不同的原因。更了解历史的人，以及更倾向于语言准确性的人，大体上，这就是争议所在。你可以看到这种转变的实际理由。
Medical workers have to stay abreast of an awful lot of terminology. You try memorizing a load of surnames in which alemen teach one represents. A list of diseases with somebody's last name as the title gives you no information and you can kind of get bungled up. Whereas you can kind of fake your way through, if you will, if the name of the disease says something about the disease itself. To use an example that was all over the news when I was growing up, CJD, Croixfelt Jacob disease, the name alone doesn't tell you much about what it is, unless you're familiar with the early 20th century work of the German neurologist Hans Gerhard Kreuzfeldt and Alfonz
医务工作者必须跟上大量的术语。你试着记住一堆姓氏，每个姓氏代表什么。以某人的姓氏为标题的疾病列表不会给你任何信息，你可能会搞混。而如果你能通过疾病名称本身了解一些关于疾病的信息，你就可以蒙混过关。举一个我成长过程中新闻里到处都是的例子，CJD，克雅氏病（Creutzfeldt-Jakob disease），单看名字并不能告诉你太多关于它是什么的信息，除非你熟悉20世纪初德国神经学家汉斯·格哈德·克罗伊茨费尔特和阿尔丰斯·
Maria Jakob. The eponym is also not easy to spell. At the far end of the scale, tabloids call the condition the human form of mad cow disease, a rather cartoonish term for a brutal and incurable illness, so the other option is the scientific term. CJD is a form of transmissible spongiform encephalitis. Encephalitis from the medical Latin encephalon from the ancient Greek encephalos, meaning brain, the itus suffix denotes inflammation. Spongiform encephalitis, to me that would be easier because that tells you something about, I mean, although it's Latin, it gives you a bit of information so you could kind of piece it together if you
玛丽亚·雅各布的工作。同源词也不容易拼写。在极端情况下，小报称这种疾病为“人类疯牛病”，对于一种残酷且无法治愈的疾病来说，这是一个相当卡通化的术语，所以另一个选择是科学术语。CJD是一种传染性海绵状脑病。Encephalitis（脑炎）源自医学拉丁语“encephalon”，源自古希腊语“encephalos”，意为大脑，“-itis”后缀表示炎症。海绵状脑病，对我来说这更容易，因为它告诉你一些关于……我的意思是，虽然它是拉丁语，但它给你提供了一点信息，所以如果你
had to. Yeah, well, spongy. Yes, spongy turns your brain to sponge, essentially. So it's all there. If anything, that's more literal than a lot of disease names would be. Yeah, I think so. Perhaps when you're receiving a diagnosis, there's some psychological protection from the grim reality of what's happening in your body being somewhat disguised by science-speak or the
不得不的话，你可以把它拼凑起来。是的，嗯，海绵状。是的，海绵状，本质上把你的大脑变成海绵。所以一切都在那里。如果说有什么不同的话，这比许多疾病名称更直白。是的，我想是这样。也许当你收到诊断结果时，科学术语或同源词的晦涩难懂，在某种程度上掩盖了你身体正在发生的残酷现实，从而提供了一些心理保护。
opaceness of an eponym. On the other hand, an overly academic or incomprehensible description of the condition can amplify a patient's stress and fear. One thing that hopefully is changing in medicine that may be ties in with this whole issue is the sort of black boxing of knowledge and the sort of protective nature of different professions. And I think it's similar to law or engineering maybe where, you know, in order to protect our jobs and to seem like we have some sort of power over the people we work with, we kind of make things possibly more difficult to understand than they need to be. And we use a jargon and a language that needs to be taught to be understood. So I don't know if there's some sort of like unconscious protectionism of our practice involved
另一方面，对疾病过于学术化或难以理解的描述会加剧病人的压力和恐惧。医学界希望改变的一件事，可能与整个问题有关，那就是知识的“黑箱化”以及不同职业的保护性。我认为这可能类似于法律或工程学，你知道，为了保护我们的工作，为了看起来我们对我们共事的人有某种权力，我们把事情弄得比实际需要更难理解。我们使用需要学习才能理解的术语和语言。所以我不知道这是否涉及某种潜意识的职业保护主义，
with naming of diseases and like, because the non-epinem names are very like complicated and don't mean a lot to people. It's it's quite a common thing in language like the Bible using quite lofty sounding language so that you maintain that division of status. But I just wonder whether there's a decent middle ground in medicine between wibbly wobbly heart disease and a long complicated name. Yeah, you don't want it so simple that you sound kind of stupid or like you don't know what's going on when you when you say it, I guess, but it's also in medicine as in everything communication is so important. And so you want to strike that middle ground where you're making sense to the
与疾病命名有关，因为非同源词名称非常复杂，对人们来说意义不大。这在语言中很常见，比如《圣经》使用非常高深的声音语言，这样你就能保持地位的差异。但我只是想知道医学界是否有一个体面的中间地带，介于“摇摇晃晃的心脏病”和长而复杂的名称之间。是的，你不想让它太简单，以至于听起来很蠢，或者当你说话时好像不知道发生了什么，我想，但在医学中，就像在所有事情中一样，沟通非常重要。所以你想找到那个中间地带，让你对
person who it's most important to, which is the patience. So in some circumstances, it's better to use the eponym because it might be more familiar. We learn about Trisomy 21, which is a genetic disorder that we're encouraged to speak about referring to the actual genetic issue, whereas Down syndrome is the common eponym. I think the lay public as well are more familiar with that language. Some concepts are really hard to describe without the eponym, and with an eponym, much more memorable. With the Heinlec maneuver, be something that people knew if it wasn't attached to a name,
最重要的人——病人——有意义。所以在某些情况下，使用同源词更好，因为它可能更熟悉。我们学习21三体综合征，这是一种遗传性疾病，我们被鼓励谈论它时参考实际的遗传问题，而唐氏综合征是常见的同源词。我认为普通大众也更熟悉那种语言。有些概念如果没有同源词真的很难描述，而有了同源词，就更容易记住。海姆利克急救法，如果它没有附带一个名字，人们会知道吗？
like, I'm like, you know, no, I don't think so. Would it have made the news in May of this year when 96-year-old Dr. Henry Heimlich himself saved a woman from choking on a piece of hamburger meat by using the maneuver that bears his name? So I still like them in these ways that they help tell an interesting story, but I totally get why then. I'm not so tied to my worldview or nostalgia that I cannot accept that it would be better another way.
就像，你知道，不，我不这么认为。如果不是96岁的亨利·海姆利克医生本人在今年5月用以他名字命名的手法救了一名被汉堡肉噎住的妇女，它会登上新闻吗？所以我仍然以这些方式喜欢它们，因为它们有助于讲述一个有趣的故事，但我完全理解为什么。我并没有那么执着于我的世界观或怀旧情结，以至于我不能接受另一种方式会更好。
Well, good, because there are certainly some aspects to eponyms that I don't think you'd like, Roman. A lot of the argument against eponyms is that it's sort of a simplification of complex stories where generally a white dead male will get the eponym. But if you look at the process of discovering and categorizing diseases, it's often over the course of more than a lifetime, and it involves many, many people. It's a false history to just use this name. Then there are ridiculous extremes where there's like four or five
好吧，很好，因为同源词中肯定有一些方面我想你不会喜欢，罗曼。反对同源词的很多论点是，这是一种对复杂故事的简化，通常是一个白人男性死者会得到这个同源词。但如果你看看发现和分类疾病的过程，它往往超过了一辈子的时间，并且涉及许多许多人。只使用这个名字是一种虚假的历史。然后还有荒谬的极端情况，比如有四五个人
people that all have a similar form of the disease named after them. And then later on they discover that it was the same disease the whole time. And then it gets all messed up. Like I have one of them written down because I can never remember it. But I think it's the longest, it's the longest eponym that I've come across. And it's a four-barreled name, if you will. And it's Mayor Rocketansky Custer Howeser Syndrome. Mayor Rocketansky Custer Howeser Syndrome is congenital abnormalities in or absence of the uterus and vagina.
都有以他们名字命名的相似形式的疾病。后来他们发现这其实一直是同一种疾病。然后一切都搞乱了。比如我写下了一个，因为我永远记不住。但我认为这是我遇到过的最长的同源词。它是一个“四管齐下”的名字，如果你愿意的话。它是梅耶-罗基坦斯基-库斯特-豪泽综合征（Mayer-Rokitansky-Küster-Hauser syndrome）。梅耶-罗基坦斯基-库斯特-豪泽综合征是子宫和阴道的先天性异常或缺失。
It sounds like four people all had some sort of a claim to the discovery of the disease. In reality, there were far more than four. People have been writing about the condition all the way back as far as the Greek physician Hippocrates in the fifth century BC. Mayor Rocketansky, Kuster and Halzer all made significant contributions
听起来好像四个人都对这种疾病的发现有某种主张。实际上，远不止四个人。人们早在公元前五世纪的希腊医生希波克拉底时代就开始撰写关于这种疾病的文章了。梅耶、罗基坦斯基、库斯特和豪泽都做出了重大贡献
to the understanding of the disease, but they weren't even working together. Mayor described the syndrome in a paper in 1829. That's 50 years before Kusta was born, 92 years before the birth of Hauser, who went on to name the disease Mayor Rockitansky Kusta syndrome. Someone else added Hauser to the end. You don't hear that disease name a lot,
对这种疾病的理解，但他们甚至没有一起工作。梅耶在1829年的一篇论文中描述了这种综合征。那是在库斯特出生前50年，在豪泽出生前92年，豪泽后来将这种疾病命名为梅耶-罗基坦斯基-库斯特综合征。有人在最后加上了豪泽。你不会经常听到那个疾病名称，
but I feel like every time I hear it, the order is a little different, so I don't even know if there's, like, a standardized name order to it. Maybe they shuffle it so that everyone gets turned at the front. Yeah, they take turns. The problem with quite a lot of epinons is the person named they're in. Writer syndrome is a condition where you get joint pain related to a kind of systemic inflammation, and it's named after Hans Ritter, who was a famous Nazi war criminal who did terrible experiments on inmates at Buchenwald.
但我感觉每次我听到它，顺序都有点不同，所以我甚至不知道是否有标准化的名称顺序。也许他们洗牌，这样每个人都能轮到前面。是的，他们轮流。很多同源词的问题在于被命名的人。赖特综合征（Reiter syndrome）是一种与某种全身性炎症相关的关节疼痛疾病，它以汉斯·赖特（Hans Reiter）的名字命名，他是一名著名的纳粹战犯，在布痕瓦尔德集中营对囚犯进行了可怕的实验。
Hans Ritter discovered the eponymous syndrome in 1916 when he treated a soldier during the First World War, prior to his Nazi affiliations, of which the American rheumatologist Dr. Ephraim Engelman was unaware when he coined the eponym in 1942, but he later joined the campaign which began in 1977 to replace the eponym with a name that doesn't honor somebody associated with war crimes and mass murder. If you don't want to evoke handswriter, you can call this condition reactive arthritis. But while usage of the eponymous term has decreased, it is still being used in medical schools and in journals. The debate raises on, do you pick and choose which parts of history are marked? Or do you allow a person's scientific achievements to be honored, despite whatever horrible things
汉斯·赖特在1916年第一次世界大战期间治疗一名士兵时发现了这个同源综合征，那是在他加入纳粹之前，美国风湿病学家埃弗拉伊姆·恩格尔曼（Ephraim Engelman）医生在1942年创造这个同源词时并不知道这一点，但他后来加入了1977年开始的运动，用一个不纪念与战争罪行和大规模谋杀有关的人的名字来取代这个同源词。如果你不想唤起汉斯·赖特，你可以称这种疾病为“反应性关节炎”。但虽然同源词的使用已经减少，但它仍然在医学院和期刊中使用。争论仍在继续，你是挑选哪些历史部分被标记？还是允许一个人的科学成就被纪念，尽管他们做了什么可怕的事情
they did? Controversial things, eponyms. There's even more controversy about eponyms where there's like a sub-conflict, if you will, going on about whether to use the possessive or not in epinems. So, there's even within people that use epinems or don't. The people that use epinems are having debates about whether it should be downs apostrophe S for possessive or down syndrome. And there's research about like which should be used in medical journals to simplify searches so that you don't have to search both terms.
他们做了什么？有争议的事情，同源词。关于同源词甚至有更多的争议，比如关于是否在同源词中使用所有格的子冲突。所以，即使在那些使用或不使用同源词的人中。使用同源词的人正在争论应该是“Down's”（带撇号S）还是“Down syndrome”（唐氏综合征）。并且有关于医学期刊中应该使用哪种形式的研究，以简化搜索，这样你就不必搜索两个术语。
I think that's the one thing I would simplify. I would get rid of all apostrophes. Wow. That seems like the right solution. C's a salad. It's not C's a salad. C's a nose. But yeah, the apostrophes, it messes it up a little too much, and you shouldn't have to think about it. There's already enough to think about. Yeah, you need to worry about the horrible disease you've got. Exactly. That you've got to cure.
我认为这是我会简化的一件事。我会去掉所有的撇号。哇。这似乎是正确的解决方案。凯撒沙拉（Caesar salad）。不是“Caesar's salad”。凯撒鼻子（Caesar nose）。但是的，撇号，它把事情搞得太乱了，你不应该去想它。已经有足够多的事情要考虑了。是的，你需要担心你患有的可怕疾病。完全正确。你必须治愈的。
And the great rich story behind the name. Yeah, there's two things. That's enough. It's enough to juggle. Something to keep you occupied in the waiting room, isn't it? Exactly. And eponym just does have so much story embedded in it. In fact, last night I was eating dinner with my kids
以及名字背后伟大的丰富故事。是的，有两件事。这就够了。在候诊室里让你忙碌起来已经足够了，不是吗？完全正确。而同源词确实嵌入了太多的故事。事实上，昨晚我和我的孩子们
and my wife. And we were talking about childbirth and mentioned the Caesarian section, the way that these two babies, you know, my twin boys came into this world. And it caused us to talk about Caesar and was Caesar really the first person to be the result of a cesarean section in which case I I have no actual knowledge of this but I said probably not it's
还有我妻子在吃晚饭。我们谈到了分娩，提到了剖腹产（Caesarian section），这两个婴儿（我的双胞胎儿子）来到这个世界的方式。这让我们谈到了凯撒，凯撒真的是第一个剖腹产的结果吗？在这种情况下，我对此没有任何实际知识，但我说可能不是，它
hard to imagine that the first person to be born through this procedure also became one of the most famous people in all of history. And invented one of the most famous salads. See, F&M searches like they're endlessly fascinating. So, but it causes great conversation at a dinner table with two nine year olds and my wife. And we had fun talking about it. And even the parts of it that are the, you know, the caveats. And generally the etymology with the tidesc story is the least true, you know, it's just like that's the nature of it.
很难想象第一个通过这种手术出生的人也成为了历史上最著名的人之一。并且发明了最著名的沙拉之一。看，同源词搜索就像它们一样无穷无尽地迷人。所以，但这在餐桌上与两个九岁的孩子和我妻子之间引发了很好的对话。我们谈论它很开心。即使是那些带有警告的部分。通常带有凯撒故事的词源是最不真实的，你知道，这就像它的本质。
Unfortunately, they're shaggy and messier than they, in general, the true ones are shaggy or messier. You have some gory, dinner table conversation. It was getting on the edge there. I mean, if you're talking messy, good grief. The Illusionist is produced by Helen Salzman with music by Martin Ostwick. Find it at theillusionist.org that's illusionist with an A, not an I. It was the first show created specifically for radio topia and I could not love it more. Subscribe now and then we can all talk about it on Twitter together. 99% Invisible Is Delaney Hall, Sheree Fusev, Avery Truffleman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sam Greenspan,
不幸的是，它们比它们更粗糙、更混乱，总的来说，真实的故事更粗糙或更混乱。你有一些血腥的餐桌谈话。那真是到了边缘。我的意思是，如果你在谈论混乱，天哪。《幻觉师》由海伦·扎尔茨曼制作，马丁·奥斯特威克配乐。在theillusionist.org找到它，那是illusionist，带一个A，不是I。它是第一个专门为RadioTopia创作的节目，我再喜欢它不过了。现在订阅，然后我们就可以一起在Twitter上谈论它了。《99%隐形》是德莱尼·霍尔、谢丽·福塞夫、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、萨姆·格林斯潘，
and me Roman Mars. Katie Mingle is our senior editor, Kurt Colstead is our digital director and Terran Mazza, is the Baroness. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Org. We're on Instagram and Tumblr too.
还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们的数字总监，泰伦·马扎是女男爵。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在广播街制作。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我，@Roman Mars，或者@该节目，@99PI Org。我们在Instagram和Tumblr上也有账号。
If you want to read about seed bullets for a guerrilla gardening or a rave review of the Atlas Obscurae book, you have to go to 99pi.org. Radio to P.O. from P.R.X. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想阅读关于游击园艺的种子弹，或者关于《奥布斯库拉地图集》书的精彩评论，你必须去99pi.org。来自PRX的RadioTopia。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。